avec beaucoup de précaution
elle quitte lentement son emplacement
elle c'est la madeleine repentante de
l'église saint nicolas une
représentation peu commune de la sainte
des marie madeleine comme celle-là on en
recense seulement une ou deux en france
elle est allongée mais c'est surtout
qu'elle a cette tête en arrière avec ses
cheveux qui recouvrent son corps et
c'est ça qui fait que cette mise en
scène finalement qui est un peu
exceptionnel en france on retrouve une
marie madeleine qui est complètement
dans cette extase rempli de l'émotion
chrétienne et c'est ce qu'ont essayé de
transmettre en fait aux fidèles à cette
époque beaucoup d'émotion dans la
religion placé à l'origine dans l'ancien
couvent des carmélites personne ne sait
exactement comment cette madeleine s'est
ensuite retrouvée dans l'église
saint-nicolas de blois elle en sort pour
la première fois depuis plus de 300 ans
avec toute l'attention dû à son grand
âge une véritable opération de sauvetage
car malgré ses centaines de kilos
l'oeuvre classé aux monuments
historiques est très vulnérable le temps
et l'humidité ont déjà détruit certains
détails de la sculpture la documentation
nous dit que elle portait une croix au
sommet d'un crâne mais on n'a pas pour
le moment suffisamment de documentation
pouvoir restituer cette partie là ce qui
est important c'est la dégradation de la
pierre qui est devenu pulvérulente donc
ça on va le stopper et
garder un état satisfaisant pour que la
sculpture puisse retourner ensuite dans
l'église sainte madeleine quitte le
loir-et-cher direction tour pour six
mois de restauration à blois on compte
aujourd'hui 60 objets protégés au titre
des monuments historiques